et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
michel barnier bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous et d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes
ancien négociateur européen pour le
break site auteurs de ce livre on va le
voir la grande illusion journal secret
du bric site c'est paru aux éditions
gallimard on va bien sûr en parler et
vous êtes membre des républicains et on
va parler de votre famille politique on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour stéphane
bern et bonjour oriane merci stéphane
d'être avec nous stéphane vous diriger
le bureau parisien du journal ouest
france
on va commencer par ce tour de france
des manuels macro michel barnier tour de
france entamé hier pour je cite
retrouver le contact aller auprès des
français pour comprendre comment ils ont
vécu la crise vous saluer la démarche du
président de la république le président
sont au contact des français ça paraît
normal ça devrait même être quotidien
donc en bien sûr et dans une campagne
électorale de personne n'est naïf mais
j'ai pas de problème j'ai sûrement pas
refaire de la polémique avec le chef de
l'état sur le fait qu'il va à l'encontre
des français sûrement pas même si vous
dites on est en campagne électorale pour
vous ce n'est qu'à l'oral donc il ya un
devoir de réserve pour les ministres
elle je vais pas la province un tour de
france avoue précieux à l'adresse pas de
faire de la polémique sur ce sujet avec
le président a vu que ça ne m'intéresse
pas j'ai autre chose à dire est autre
chose à faire voilà comment ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le fond qu'on sorte de
cette pandémie et qu'on vaccine les plus
jeunes et sur l'argent j'entends qu'ils
l'annoncent le gouvernement annonce des
mesures pour le tourisme qui est une
économie majeure
j'ai été président d'un conseil général
la savoie pendant 17 ans dont une partie
de l'économie repose sur le tourisme
d'été et d'hiver
j'aurais d'ailleurs pour tout vous dire
mieux compris qu'on ne ferme pas les
remontées mécaniques cet hiver comme
d'autres pays l'ont fait aujourd'hui on
éviterait peut-être de compenser des
pertes d'activités qu'on aurait pu
éviter les choses sont faites le moment
n'est pas de donner des leçons mais
plutôt de tirer des leçons
je trouve bien qu'on apporte un soutien
à l'économie touristique parce que c'est
un actif majeur pour notre pays c'est un
actif qui nous permet de jouer notre
rôle est peut-être d'appuyer cette
ambition que j'ai pour pour la france et
que j'ai indiquées de d'être mon 10 ou
la première puissance économique
d'europe
si on veut atteindre cet objectif tous
ensemble il faut que tout le monde s'y
met évidemment l'activité agricole
activité industrielle des petites et
moyennes entreprises et le tourisme
100 des actifs sur lesquels nous devons
nous appuyer pour réussir ce pari
et justement on va parler des aides du
voilà juste peut-être avant de passer à
l'acte urnes mais puisque vous le
puisque vous l'évoquez le tourisme la
montagne un mot sur le plan de montagne
présenté par jean castex la semaine l'un
présentait d'ailleurs dans un canton je
connais bien et dont il était le
conseiller général pendant 27 ans à
bourg saint maurice en haute tarentaise
région de sa venue en tarentaise et je
pense que c'est un plan qui est solide
et qui était salué comme tel par la
profession mais encore une fois j'aurais
mieux compris j'avais d'ailleurs dit au
premier ministre avant qu'il ne prenne
cette décision qu'on ne ferme pas ou pas
brutalement ou pas complètement les
remontées mécaniques qui était dès
qu'ils sont les transports publics des
précautions possibles
j'ai des protocoles qui permettait comme
ça s'est passé dans d'autres pays
voisins des alpes de préserver une
partie des activités touristiques
ce qui éviterait aujourd'hui de donner
des crédits pour compenser on va passer
à l'actualité de la semaine le
gouvernement a présenté hier un budget
rectificatif est ce que c'est la bonne
méthode de ce2 de sortie du quoi qu'il
en coûte pour vous alors on peut pas
continuer à être dans le quoi qu'il en
coûte à ouvrir les vannes sens
mieux gérer ou bien gérer le budget de
l'état et on peut pas en sortir non plus
brutalement il faut une période de trois
ans mais le jeu n'est pas critique à
faire sur cette sortie cabu pour vous
j'ai été député pendant très longtemps
et on a souvent présenté pratiquement
chaque année des les doigts de finances
rectificative et même parfois plusieurs
donc comment on en sort tu sais quoi
qu'il en coûte pour vous c'est quoi la
bonne méthode pour l'europe sans
continuer si l'activité repart s'il ya
plus de besoins du chômage partiel on va
pas continuer à payer du chômage partiel
donc on en sort progressivement
et puis il faut dire la vérité aux mots
citoyens parce que les citoyens
attendent eux des hommes politiques
langage de vérité de dignité et de
sincérité il faudra bien rembourser
cette dette même si on l'a hambourg sur
plusieurs dizaines d'années une dette
doit être remboursé c'est une question
de confiance et de respect d'honneur
même pour la signature française devance
et de quelle manière le gouvernement dit
pas d'augmentation de taxes pas
d'augmentation d'impôts vous êtes sur
cette ligne vous aussi de quelle manière
on l'a regardé ses yeux son autre pays
par rapport à nos voisins vous voyez
bien qu'on ait trop taxer le travail
l'emploi est taxé c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi j'ai proposé qu'on supprime sur
cinq ans ce qu'on appelle les impôts de
production qui n'existe pas dans nos
pays voisins et concurrents et qui
plombent l'économie des petites poignées
entreprises l'agriculture donc il faut
qu'on se remette à égalité donc sûrement
augmenter l'impôt bien gérer des
finances publiques nous en reparlons
dans les mois qui viennent et puis faire
repartir ce pays le pari de l'activité
il faut que le pays repart notre pays a
beaucoup de problèmes je pense qu'ils
étaient gérés de manière trop
centralisée trop solitaire il ya plein
de ressources plein de ressort je visite
les régions une fois par semaine je
serai cette semaine en bretagne la
semaine prochaine auprès d'aurélien
pradié en occitanie je sais j'étais la
semaine dernière dans le grotesque je
vois partout des usines des entreprises
petites et grandes d'agriculteurs qui
ont envie de repartir sur des idées qui
ont de l'imagination quand de la
ténacité il faut les encourager
mais ce que relancer l'activité ça va
suffire michel barnier s il va falloir
faire des économies faire des réformes
et quand pour vous nous avons bien sûr
d'argentât de réforme a à proposer pour
mieux gérer l'état et pour qu'il soit
plus efficace paie le moment souviendra
de données c'est un dysfonctionnement
côté franchement je vais pas sur votre
plateau même si j'ai envie de vous faire
plaisir
présenter un programme le moment n'est
pas venu de le fermer
j'indique vous le voyez j'ai sur
l'immigration et sur le pari de
l'activité le retour à l'activité
remettre nos entreprises à égalité de
chances avec les entreprises
concurrentes mais non bannir mais juste
pour finir sur ces questions budgétaires
parce que vous connaissez bien
évidemment l'union européenne ni en
plaine a décidé hier que les règles
budgétaires resteraient suspendus pour
le moment
est-ce qu'on va vers la fin de la règle
des 3% je pense qu'on va adapter cette
règle même s'il faut un règlement de
copropriété pour l'euro n'ayons pas la
mémoire courte
moi j'ai dû gérer comme commissaire
européen la crise financière j'étais là
nous nommé par nicolas sarkozy qui avait
beaucoup travaillé sur la feuille de
route du g20 au lendemain de la crise
financière
gerba t-il architecture de régulation
mais j'ai pas oublié comment notre
continent l'europe la france endettée
télescoper par cette crise parce que
nous étions désarmés sur 2,2 points nous
avions dérégulé à l'excès et les marchés
financiers donc à savon de banquiers se
sont cru tout permis
on leur a tout permis et puis on avait
une monnaie unique mais pas de budget
coordonnées donc on a corrigé et en
corriger je pense que cette crise est
venu impacter cette démarche mais je
pense que c'est sage de la panure open
de donner plus de flexibilité on nous
avait dit que les 3%
concrètement c'est dépassé pour vous
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ils sont
suspendus
évidemment c'est la réalité il va
falloir y revenir je pense qu'il faudra
revenir un règlement une forme de
règlement de copropriété de la zone euro
et on va en discuter ça sera sans doute
différent et plus de règles strictes
je pense qu'il faudra t des règles
d'encadrement mais je ne peux pas dire
aujourd'hui le résultat d'une discussion
qui vient tout juste de commencer
anthémis des finances et la commission
européenne
autre sujet vous défendez l'idée d'un
moratoire de 3 à 5 ans sur l'immigration
en europe est ce que vous pourriez vous
nous expliquer ce qu'est ce qui vous
motive quelle est l'idée personne ne
peut dire que l'immigration la politique
d'immigration française marche bien dit
d'ailleurs la politique européenne
on voit bien ce qui se passe est sacré
dans notre pays beaucoup de ruptures
beaucoup de tension assez grave je pense
j'ai souvenir je raconte dans mon livre
le conseil va donner angela merkel un
soir vers 23h dans un conseil européen
auquel je participais avec les chefs
d'état sur le président nous étions
bloqués sur la question irlandaise et
elle me dit michel
moi je suis scientifique quand j'ai un
problème est là nous étions devant un
vrai problème
je prend 3,3 pas de recul et puis je
regarde en anglais on dit le global
pictures jours je regarde l'image
globale parce que ça m'aide d'avoir une
image plus large bon donc c'est ce que
je propose ne s'agit pas d'arrêter
l'immigration il s'agit de traiter avec
justice humanité et rigueur
les personnes qui viennent chez nous
soit qu'il s'agisse le personnes qui
veulent immigrer chez nous pour des
raisons économiques soit il s'agit de
l'étudiant soit il s'agit de personnes
qui sont réfugiés qui ont droit au titre
de réfugiés c'est une question aussi lié
à notre à nos valeurs on sait qu'il ya
des abus
on sait qu'il ya des détournements il
sait qu'il ya des trafics qui sont
absolument inqualifiable d'enfants de
femmes dans deux dom
à travers elles tirent année donc je
propose qu'on prenne le temps qu'on
marque une pause qu'on regarde chacune
de ces procédures chez nous de manière
intelligente peut être avec la moratoire
différencier dans le temps selon les
populations comprennent le temps de
travailler avec nos partenaires et
voisins les frontières européennes ne
fonctionne pas bien
il faut contrôler tout ce qui rentre
chez nous et on peut le faire comme les
américains le font peu de discuter des
accords de dublin du renforcement de
schengen du renforcement de frontex et
on doit discuter troisième raison de
cette pause observatoire avec les pays
d'où viennent toutes ces personnes il y
a le codéveloppement common
contractualise l'aide au développement
au niveau européen comment on gère les
visas il ya plein de choses à discuter
avec eux tous ceux qui sont de l'autre
côté de la méditerranée sur le contrôle
des frontières puisque clément ghosn le
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes il dit qu un pays qui n'est
pas sérieux sur le contrôle de ses
frontières et doit pouvoir être
sanctionné il dit on doive et on doit
pouvoir vérifier ça comme on vérifie le
déficit vous êtes d'accord avec jacques
ce que je viens de vous
à toi des pays qui sur les sanctions je
ne sais pas très bien ce que ça veut
dire des sanctions contre un pays comme
la grèce ou l'italie qui est l'objet
d'une pression migratoire extraordinaire
nous aurons besoin peut-être davantage
de sanctions de coopération et de faire
ce que monsieur juncker avait commencé à
faire c'est à dire de créer un corps
européen de garde frontières de
garde-côtes ya 10000 postes qui sont en
cours de création je pense que c'est
tout juste suffisante il faut équiper
toutes ses frontières et des cps équipés
de matériels modernes qui permettent
l'identification des personnes qui
rentrent chez nous je sais pas si
monsieur ghosn a parlé de sanctions je
pense qu'il faut une vraie coopération
et qu'on prenne en charge collectivement
mutualisant mutualisant la gestion des
frontières au niveau européen allez on
va parler de votre livre mais si on
avait un peu parlé mais on va plus
précisément parler de votre livre la
grande illusion c'est une plongée dans
les négociations de ce break site
stéphane on commence avec vous ouais
avant de parler de briques site
prochaine j'aimerais y revient vous
évoquiez eu une conversation et quand
angela merkel votre livre fourmille
d'anecdotes en plus de 2,2 du ratio
quasiment au jour le jour de ses quatre
années de négociations intenses parmi
ces anecdotes vous revient à plusieurs
reprises sur sur la montagne
on apprend notamment que theresa may est
une passionnée de randonnée en montagne
que vous avez offert un bâton de marche
et à david davis ça c'est un signe à
escoeuilles ne comment dire dans le dans
les coulisses des négociations ça fait
partie des des petits trucs que vous
utilisez au fait vous créer des
solidarités de montagnards avec vos
interlocuteurs et d'autres ils sont pas
tous montagnards un vibrateur on a dit
quand cela d'abord indique simplement
que moi je suis définitivement attaché à
ce pays de la savoie de des alpes où
j'ai ma famille beaucoup d'amis mes
racines et les premiers témoignages que
je pouvais gagner la confiance des
citoyens puisque j'ai été élu là j'avais
22 ans dans ce canton dont on parlait
tout à l'heure
et puis le sacré une complicité fin de
convivialité nous theresa may adore la
montagne va faire de grandes marches
mais aussi un peu suffisent elles à
l'heure les alpes suisses et même et
séchés sont les bains alpes et donc
peut-être aussi les tétées l'idée de
dire que vous jettez engagés dans cette
négociation dans une très grande
randonnée très longue
moi je donc que prévu plus longue que
c'est à quoi oui la santé en tout cas
n'ont que prévu je pensais pas que ça
dure et pour la première et zone avait
renégocié de traiter 1 pour le principe
politique la sortie de les institutions
européennes et le deuxième pour les
anglais voulaient aller très très vite
est ce que finalement je sais pas s'il
voulait très vite en tout cas à la fin
c'est plutôt qu'ils ont fait une sorte
de guerre des nerfs pour nous amener
jusqu'au 24 décembre
à 12h06 m'a d'ailleurs privé d'un noël
en famille je raconterai ce livre mais
mais on était prêt j'avais fait du calme
du respect des anglais une méthode de
négociations
je leur avais dit vous n'arriverez pas à
m'énerver donc nous sommes restés calmes
même si nous sommes restés très ferme
pour défendre les intérêts des
entreprises des agriculteurs des
pêcheurs des citoyens repéré au bout de
la route
je rappelle que ceux qui sont partis
c'est pas nous qui avons quitté le
royaume uni c'est eux qui nous ont
quittés donc il n'y avait aucune raison
qu en nous quittant il
ils fragilisent le marché unique vous
rappeler aussi qu'il ya le lol le
royaume uni l'angleterre fin dans
l'union européenne c'est 759 accord avec
168 pays dont 69 sur la pêche 65 sur les
transports 49 sur les douanes 45 sur le
nucléaire
on sort pas comme ça de doudin d'un
écheveau pareil en un claquement de
doigt pour sa fallu négocier tout pied à
pied jusqu'à la dernière minute par
exemple sur la pêche
oui mais c'est pour ça que ça a pris du
temps parce que ils ont quitté 47 ans de
coopération pendant lesquelles on la
construit ensemble
ce cadre européen qui ont bien davantage
qu'une zone de libre-échange marché
unique c'est un écosystème pour 22
millions d'entreprises pour 450 millions
aujourd'hui de citoyens consommateurs
avec des règles des normes dérégulation
des gens quitter tout ça je crois qu'ils
n'ont pas fini de mesurer les
conséquences
je pense pour ça que j'ai appelé celui
de la grande illusion c'est que je pense
est une illusion de croire que dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui où personne ne se
fait de cadeau peut-être nous espère un
peu nous français ou européen mais plus
personne ne nous attend dans le monde
aujourd'hui c'est une illusion de croire
qu on est plus forts tout seul vis-à-vis
de monsieur by donné hier de monsieur
troubles il la chine vis-à-vis de la
russie
il faut être ensemble et ensemble
appuient sur un marché qui est la
principale raison pour laquelle on nous
respecte
et c'est ce marché s'était construite
plus 47 ans vous avez l'impression vous
qu'il y avait beaucoup négocié avec eux
qu'ils avaient mesuré toutes les
conséquences du rexy certainement pas
certainement pas je les dis nous avons
dit j'ai dit oh pour du tout début de ma
mission en 2016 le brésil a énormément
de conséquences humaines sociales pour
quatre millions et demi de citoyens dont
on à protéger les droits économiques
pour la paix chez l'agriculteur les
entreprises
juridique technique financière politique
avec peut-être des conséquences
systémiques plus tard mais non je ne
crois pas qu'ils j'ai bien expliqué les
conséquences je pense qu'il ya eu un
certain nombre de mensonges aussi eu
comme un livre il ya aussi le fait que
vous avez négocié un accord longtemps
puis de pied à pied très précis très
encadré le problème c'est que là on voit
depuis la négociation depuis
l'aboutissement des choses dans
l'application des accords y à il ya
quelques couacs
on va dire je pense notamment à la pêche
par exemple ce qui se passe en irlande
ou en fait finalement on voit que les
britanniques roches ils traînent des
pieds où on cherche des billets pour ne
pas appliquer ce qu'ils ont eux mêmes
signés qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire par
rapport par rapport à ces cas précis
dans le suivi de l'application des actes
de la jambière gauche de suivi et moi je
pense que le gouvernement
chez nous comme ailleurs doit attacher
autant d'importance sinon plus à l'effet
de suivi causé fed annonce est donc
aujourd'hui je recommande gelé dira
d'ailleurs le dernier jour de la
négociation prenons garde à
l'application de ce traité qui est
complet précis de traiter en fait de
1400 pages et nous avions déjà eu des
alertes
parce que les britanniques depuis un an
et demi montrent bien qu'ils ne veulent
pas appliquer l'accord qu'ils ont signé
qui l'ont ratifié pour l'irlande en iran
de ses plus grave parce que c'est pas
une question de marchandises de commerce
c'est l'appel à la paix auquel les gens
d'irlande attache du prix parce que ça
fait à peine 20 ans que le conflit en
irlande du nord s'est arrêté après 4000
morts quatre mille morts donc quand j'ai
j'ai toujours eu ce souci de la paix en
irlande et je recommande vraiment que
chacun fasse attention d'ailleurs tout
le monde observe ce qui se passe en
irlande y compris le président bailly
donne comme il l'a dit publiquement
donc pour la pêche comme pour l'irlande
il faut que les britanniques simplement
respecteur signature c'est une question
d'honneur une question de responsabilité
une question de confiance et s'ils
veulent dans le temps qu on coopère
intelligemment il faut qu'on ait
confiance et permettez moi de dire c'est
aussi une troisième souci que jure de la
défense des intérêts de l'europe c'est
que j'ai voulu préserver l'esprit de
coopération parce que
ya tellement de défis qui sont devant
nous d'autres pandémies il faut dire la
vérité il y aura d'autres d'autres
pandémie humaine ou animale le
terrorisme
le changement climatique la pauvreté les
turbulences financières
voilà tout ce qui est vendu je veux pas
de catastrophisme et il faut être prêt
il faut être responsable et dans
certains de ces défis et au mieux être
ensemble avec les britanniques
un dernier mot stéphane là dessus avant
de parler aux deux passeurs et juste
peut-être sur leurs excuses moi
d'insister mais pas réglé sur la pêche
qui est un sujet qui intéresse beaucoup
les bretons quels sont les leviers dont
on dispose pour faire pression sur les
britanniques pour les obliger à
respecter leurs leur signature
alors je vais en bretagne dès cet après
midi et demain jour j'aurai plusieurs
moments de rencontres auxquelles je
tiens avec les pêcheurs ils ont raison
de demander qu'on respecte signature
nous devons les soutenir le gouvernement
français la commission européenne pourra
vers les licences notamment dans la
manche autour des îles anglo-normandes
hier un accord a été passé entre les
britanniques et lots l'union européenne
pour l'application de ces accords de
pêche en 2021 nous y sommes c'est une
bonne chose il faut faire pression
alors comment qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
mais il faut leur dire que si ça ne va
pas on ira des mesures comme nous avons
prévu dans le traité compensatoires on
peut rétablir des droits de douane sur
certains produits de pêche les
maquereaux et autres on peut suspendre
l'accès des britanniques à nos autos je
ne souhaite pas qu'on en arrive là on
peut mettre en cause tout ou partie de
l'accord si jamais il ya des atteintes
graves à la signature et la confiance
j'espère qu'on sera raisonnable mais
qu'on voudra bien mettre ce qui est
important c'est ces accords en
perspective la perspective que je vous
ai dit d'une coopération intelligente
entre l'union européenne et le royaume
uni nous allons en avoir besoin
une dernière chose sur le sujet avant de
passer à la politique pure
est-ce que vous pensez que que tout ça
à vacciner les français ou est ce que
par exemple la possibilité d'un d'un
afrique site existe encore ouzou plus
personne n'en parle ou c'est je ne
comprends pas qu'en guise conclusion
qu'on vous ne fascine ou pas alors tout
cas cette négociation a montré ce que ça
voulait dire quitté l'union européenne
d'abord c'est pas une prison l'union
européenne on peut la quitter mais on
prend ces risques et on assume les
responsabilités sont plus grave
peut-être que les britanniques le
non-dit au britannique ce même mais il
ya des leçons à tirer et moi je pense en
effet que après avoir géré un événement
improbable pendant quatre ans mais qui
fait produit il faut faire attention à
d'autres situations improbables qui
peuvent se produire parce qu'il ya des
raisons qui sont partout les mêmes
notamment la colère sociale et
incendient des pieds là aujourd'hui on
dit chez nous n'est présent dans
beaucoup de régions le sentiment d'être
abandonnés de ne pas avoir de service
public ne plus avoir d'industrie de
d'avoir une immigration mal maîtrisé ce
sentiment là populaire c'est pas du
populisme
il faut l'écouter sentiment populaire
mais pourquoi moi je vais à la rencontre
des français c'est pour l'écouter
comprendre et apporter des réponses
objectives sérieuse opérationnel à ces
questions il faut faire attention à ce
que je pense je serais presque acquis
juste ce message il faut faire attention
à michèle bernier est ce que ça
s'adresse au gouvernement elle
aujourd'hui à celui de demain ça
s'adresse à des hommes politiques comme
moi qui doivent ouvrir les yeux et se
dire que les raisons qui ont conduit
auprès site on en à la trace la réalité
chez nous et dans d'autres pays
européens il faut aussi qu'on chine
apporte des réponses à bruxelles il ya
des choses à changer à bruxelles on n'a
peut-être pas le temps d'en parler il ya
des choses à corriger ya trop de
bureaucratie et eu trop
d'ultralibéralisme il ya trop de
timidité sur la politique industrielle
et ça change sur le fait de négliger la
réciprocité dans ces gens j'ai eu trop
de naïveté
il ya des choses à changer à bruxelles
mais toutes les réponses sont pas
cherché à vos seuil en à paris canada
les régions les transports publics les
circuits courts agricoles
donc je sais c'est ça le combat qui
m'intéresse pour les temps qui viennent
on va finir en parlant de votre famille
politique
et de la faire entre guillemets guillon
qualité ce matin dans les colonnes du
figaro christian jacob le président de
votre parti recadre guillaume pelletier
nous n'avons rien de commun avec marine
le pen ces déclarations nous ont
fragilisés et je ne les partage pas vous
avez parlé de foot vous attendait des
explications de guillaume pelletier est
ce que ce recadrage de christian jacob
il doit deal doit aller plus loin il
doit déboucher sur quelque chose est
sûre quoi pour vous est ce que guillaume
pelletier a encore sa place au genre de
public un style américain
il a dit ce qu'il pensait dans une
réunion ces jours ci le problème qui
s'est posé c'est que il a exprimé une
opinion personnelle en tant que vice
président du parti et il n'y a pas eu de
travail collégial ou collectifs avant et
j'ai c'est ça qui n'est pas acceptable
c'est ça que j'ai a qualifié de faute
maintenant je vais pas ajouter d'autres
choses à ce qu'a dit le président de
notre parti nous avons beaucoup de
turbulences actuellement il ya beaucoup
de tentations aux tentatives on l'a vu
dans le région paca pour nous
déstabiliser pour essayer même de
dynamiter pour moi je pense est une
erreur c'est tout je pense que
l'exécutif joue avec le feu en voulant
faire le vide entre lui et le le front
national dans le midi moi je veux dire
mon soutien renaud muselier qui est un
bon président et et nous résistons et je
pense que ne rien rien de toutes ces
turbulences nous empêchera de cesser de
construire l'unité de la famille
politique et le projet qu'attendent les
français et elle est encore possible
cette unité est ce qu'aujourd'hui les
républicains tels qu'ils sont ils ont
encore un sens c'est ce qu'il ne faut
pas tout reconstruire actes et que
désormais il ya deux lignes très très
différentes sinon il n'y a pas de ligne
dans cette famille politique moi je n'ai
jamais quitté et je suis fier d'avoir
été militant gaulliste quand j'avais 14
ou 15 ans il ya toujours des
sensibilités différentes et toujours des
gens qui étaient plusieurs droites plus
européen - européens plus souverainiste
plus à gauche du tout moi j'appartiens
au gaullisme social et progressistes et
donc je viendrai toujours 700 cas que
nous nous gagnons quand nous ressemblons
à la france et nous perdons quand nous
nous recroquevillerons donc l'objectif
c'est précisément de faire l'unité et
c'est ce à quoi je veux travailler dans
les mois qui viennent avec tout ce dont
on parlait beaucoup d'autres pour
préserver cette unité être capable de
présenter un candidat
seul aux élections présidentielles je
pense est une des clés pour éviter que
les événements improbables se produisent
en france mais pis pour mettre fin aux
turbulences que vous évoquez parce que
ce qui manque au parti républicain
aujourd'hui c'est un leadership très
incarnée d'avoir un candidat ou une
candidate
précisément ce dont je parle alors quand
c'est le bon timing c'est quoi au timing
et la méthode le bon timing c'est
précisément d'abord de mettre un pas
devant l'autre jeudi j'étais montagnard
est d'abord de faire attention la
situation de la france les français
souffrent et beaucoup de beaucoup de
détresse beaucoup de difficultés avec
cette crise du coc vite beaucoup de
morts beaucoup de souffrance dans ce
pays il faut respecter ça qu'on en sorte
qu'on refasse repartir ce pays et compte
et les gens retrouvent de l'espoir
notamment les jeunes après il ya les
élections régionales et départementales
qui sont très importantes et il s'agit
d'un vie quotidienne j'ai dit a été
présent d'un département pendant 17 ans
c'est la vie quotidienne elle transporte
l'action économique et l'action sociale
et b bien d'autres sujets encore qui
atteint sa vie kotick et puis le monde
viendra à l'automne à l'automne pour lui
je pense après l'été qu'on décide enfin
de se mettre autour d'une table et
d'avoir une analyse lucide de la
situation de créer une équipe
comment l'accusé france le paradoxe est
que nous avons une capacité de créer
belle équipe de france elle a besoin
d'une bonne équipe pour gérer ce pays
mais il manque un capitanat l'équipe
faut simplement désigner un chef
d'equipe y a pas d'homme providentiel et
pour trouver ce capitaine ce chef
d'equipe vous passerez par une primaire
ni faut une primaire pour moi je ne
pense pas qu'une première soit
indispensable
10 à la musique qui monte au sein du
parti oui nous avons certains la font
remonter mais est ce qu'on a besoin
d'une polémique ou de surenchère ou je
ne crois pas je crois qu'on peut s'en
passer si on fait une analyse lucide de
la situation et qu'on choisisse entre
nous celui qui peut être le chef
d'équipé du néant si c'est le dernier
nous verrons bien nous verrons bien j'ai
dit que je m'engagerai dans cette dans
ce débat pour l'unité je ne ferai rien
qui
provoquerait une quelconque division de
ma famille politique n'en a pas besoin
je suis prêtre et l'unité je n'engagerai
je serai présent rendez-vous simplement
merci beaucoup merci dernier d'avoir été
notre invité je rappelle le titre de
votre livre la grande illusion c'est
paru aux éditions gallimard merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité à
regarder une de ouest france le dauphin
d'angela merkel se confie à ouest france
est à la une de votre journal stéphane
merci messieurs
[Musique]